the rock uh it's a thrill to meet you as
a matter of fact uh before i even talk
about your movies your career your
wrestling everything
you met hank the angry drunken dwarf
didn't you i did yes yeah you have a
remembrance i did yeah yeah and i
couldn't believe it because last night i
was watching uh you know the e and i
guess it was the first time he came on
the show and then i was listening to you
guys this morning i can't believe he
passed away
so uh you know my condolences there the
rock go ahead please
well i first met hank yes
a couple of years ago yes how long ago
was this it was probably it was probably
about two years ago two years ago in uh
nassau coliseum
right uh at least gary reminded me where
it was yeah what was going on you were
wrestling
i think yeah there was an event we had
and it was hank and um
and uh bob you even know what that you
could care less what they were no i
really didn't know what they were doing
you knew what you were doing and that's
awesome
wrestling so the rock what happened
after what happened to the hank after
the rock metal
the rock bumped into the hank and he
came up to what your knee yeah but first
of all i didn't even you know again i
bumped into him i turned around so i
said oh i'm sorry my man he's like
he's like god go f
is yourself what he said that's exactly
what he said a man of your size a
muscular rock stature he told me go f
off
really were you shocked i started
laughing
that's
fantastic
you you and you let him slide i shook
the hank's hand and you did so the rock
shook the hank's hand indeed a special
remembrance from the rock